[Music]
from a dazzling performance by a former
Nickelodeon actor to a runtime that goes
on just a bit too long these are the
best and worst moments of director
baslerman's Elvis if you're a fan of
Rock movies Elvis really captures what a
rock film should be it's big
over-the-top bombastic colorful and
moves along at a Breakneck Pace these
are of course all trademarks of
baslerman's work and his frenetic style
is a great fit for the incredible rocket
Rider Presley's life Elvis captures
what's sadly missing from Rock today the
Royal Primal energy and sexual angst
that made the music explode lerman's
enthusiasm and passion are off the
charts and you can't help but feel it
pouring off the screen with Elvis Lerman
shows us why Elvis hit like a bomb when
he first came along the 50s were
repressed time and when he hits the
stage for the first time performing Baby
Let's Play House the audience can't help
but go wild the film captures how rock
and roll made people feel how it pushed
the right buttons and how the energy on
stage and in the audience fed off each
other creating a perfect storm of
excitement not only can Elvis stand
proud of the great Rock movies of Cinema
history but it truly captures the spirit
to the music more so than any other Rock
film in recent memory Elvis like a lot
of movies these days is simply too long
the run time for the film is 159 minutes
and while this it certainly is not
boring for minutes there are definitely
moments where audiences can feel the
movie running out of steam as the pacing
starts to lag a bit Elvis Presley's life
and career make for a big story that
goes without saying and there's a lot of
ground to cover trying to capture his
life in anything less than two hours
would give the man short shrift but
again with the film pushing three hours
it runs the risk of feeling overstuffed
while it's hard to imagine what could
reasonably be cut from the film if
Lerman tightened things up here and
there it definitely would have helped a
great deal in keeping the initial
momentum on Pace throughout the picture
Elvis is a very well made film and it's
a knockouts on the big screen all the
technical aspects of the film including
the cinematography production design and
costumes are top-notch bazlerman used
his regular cinematographer Mandy Walker
to shoot the film and she did a terrific
job Elvis also has a number of lengthy
musical numbers and the Recreations of
the 1968 Comeback Special in Presley's
Vegas shows are amazing the musical
numbers in the film have so much energy
you get tired watching them and like
Presley himself Butler gives it
everything he's got while he's on stage
Elvis is so well made and so big in
scope that it's hard to believe that the
film only cost a reported 85 million
dollars it looks like it cost way more
and every penny is up there on the
screen one of the odd things about Elvis
is his marriage to Priscilla feels very
underwritten in fact Priscilla as a
character feels more like an
afterthought than an important person in
Presley's life Olivia dejong's
performance as Priscilla is fine but the
movie doesn't give her much to do and
when the marriage finally falls apart
Elvis is clearly devastated but the
audience doesn't feel his despair
furthermore you don't feel that invested
in the relationship because it's nowhere
near as passionate as the musical
numbers even in a movie that's nearly
three hours long there are going to be
areas of Presley's life that will get
scant attention or no attention at all
but the romance between Elvis and
Priscilla definitely needed more screen
time playing Elvis is a role any young
actor would kill for it's also one of
the most frightening and challenging
roles an actor can take on you not only
have to get the look the dance moves and
the voice right but you also have to get
the essence of the man Austin Butler was
previously best known for performing on
Nickelodeon and the Disney Channel shows
like Hannah Montana and Wizards of
Waverly Place and he knew very well he
was taking a big risk playing one of the
most beloved figures in rock history the
whole beginning process of this was was
me kind of going do I believe I can do
it as Butler told nme the first time he
wore Elvis's iconic black leather outfit
he was truly terrified the actor
recalled had done so much work but at
that moment I thought if this doesn't go
well the whole film could fall apart and
my career is over let's make her break
thankfully Butler absolutely pulled it
off and to see him nail Presley as a
remarkable Star is Born moment one of
the biggest controversy surrounding
Elvis is Tom Hanks performance as
Presley's Infamous manager Colonel Tom
Parker Parker was of European descent
and Hanks performs the role with an odd
accent that many have found off-putting
even Parker's biographer Alana Nash has
said that Hank Scott Parker's accent
wrong I had to find a way out
she told variety that Parker's real
accent was more American more rural
ultimately Hank's accent is an acquired
taste and you'll either go with it or
you won't yet Hank's performance and
accents are nowhere near as bad as his
detractors are saying and in some ways
his voice even adds to the creepiness of
the character
not a huge Elvis fan don't know anything
about the guy not a problem you
absolutely don't have to be an Elvis
fanatic to enjoy the movie although the
film could go a long way in converting
newcomers into Presley devotees funnily
enough you don't have to be a bazlerman
fan to like the movie either the
Australian director has a fast-paced
frenetic style that's not for everyone
but with Elvis he pulls you right into a
very entertaining and engrossing movie
Elvis is a great starting point for new
fans it's essentially Elvis 101 showing
the broad Strokes of the King's life and
career and sets up a good foundation for
newcomers to get hooked on his music as
well the rock and roll biopic usually
follows a familiar pattern we've all
seen many times over an artist has a
rise a fall a resurrection and often a
tragic end while Elvis has many great
musical numbers impacts a strong visual
punch its storyline is very simplistic
and it often feels too on the nose and
obvious to be fair the story of Elvis's
life has been retold countless times and
while Lerman found an exciting visual
way to tell the story it often falls
into cliches we've seen in Too Many
Music biopics the list it's great to
watch Elvis dance in front of his
screaming audience for the first time
but it feels a little hokey that Presley
can't figure out what's driving the
girls crazy until the band tells him the
film also shows Elvis literally lost in
a house of mirrors as he's trying to
figure out his identity then when he
decides to make Colonel Parker his
manager and make their pact at a
carnival which is an obvious symbol of
the circus his life is about to become
Elvis's death also cannot get more
obvious when the king boards his private
plane the Lisa Marie and it vanishes off
into the clouds symbolizing his Ascent
into heaven in other words Elvis is
certainly not subtle if you're looking
for a movie with nuanced death
thought-provoking subtext and an
Innovative groundbreaking storyline well
this isn't it when a retro movie is done
right it can truly make you feel like
you've been taken back in time in this
regard Elvis is a wonderful time machine
that Barry Faithfully recreates the 50s
60s and 70s in great detail even if you
weren't alive when Elvis walked the herb
the film has an authenticity to it where
you're convinced that's how the world
really was in those days and it's a
wonderful trip to go back to a world
where there was no internet fans
couldn't film concerts with their
smartphones and there was no social
media who hell is that it's that boy
romantic when Elvis became a major
Superstar it really meant something
because he didn't build his career on a
reality TV show like American Idol back
then entertainment wasn't as accessible
as it is today and going to see the man
in concert really felt like a major
event Elvis revisits a time when
entertainers felt more legendary and
were more mysterious to the public
before they eventually crashed down to
earth when watching Elvis it's clear
that Lerman came to praise him not to
bury him watching the film it's clear
that it could have done more to show the
Dark Side of Presley of which there was
plenty to dissect especially in the
later years when he became a sad cell
parody the fans made Presley a God but
the man was certainly not a saint and
some online critics have pointed out how
Elvis should be called to task for
grooming Priscilla when she was 14 and
for cultural appropriation and of course
you have to wonder if Elvis would be
canceled today like so many other
celebrities who engage in sexual
misconduct Elvis is a story told in
Broad Strokes doesn't have Shades of
Gray but it could have made a much more
interesting and complex film if Lerman
showed more of the dark side
not to make the film more titillating
but to show that he really was only
Human After All a standout moment in
Elvis is the song If I Can Dream a
poignant call for peace as the 60s were
ending in turmoil Elvis performed this
song in his 68 Comeback Special and its
social commentary is also right on time
with current events in 1968 the world
was devastated by the assassinations of
Robert Kennedy and Martin Luther King Jr
in the film Elvis is profoundly affected
as well and wants to say something but
he's discouraged by Colonel Parker from
making a political statement against his
manager's wishes he performs If I Can
Dream and it becomes a statement to the
world with a message similar to John
Lennon's imagine Elvis truly sings his
heart out on dream and it's one of the
most impassioned performances of his
career the scene is intercut with news
footage of President Lyndon B Johnson
denouncing gun violence and with the
recent mass shootings that have rocked
the country in modern times the scene
hits home heart today it was a song the
world needed then and it's a song the
world needs today yes at times Elvis can
feel bloated over the top in cliche that
she would say the same about the man
himself despite the film's imperfections
and flaws enough sticks to the wall that
Elvis ultimately comes out of winter
it's a story that's been told many times
over but it's how Lerman told the story
that sets it apart from the standard
Rock biopic whatever the film lacks it
more than makes up for with his passion
and enthusiasm not just for Elvis but
for rock and roll as well Butler and
Lerman made the right combination to
bring Elvis's story to the big screen
and you get the impression they both
gave this movie everything they had just
as Elvis loved performing to the point
of exhaustion Butler and Lerman pushed
themselves to the limits as well of
course the king himself can't be here to
enjoy his latest comeback but he'd
probably be thrilled he's still
remembered and that his biopic is
creating a new generation of fans will
there be more movies about Elvis in the
future probably will they have a hard
time topping this one absolutely right
they will
[Music]